Let's draw a diagrams that we can better visualize what's going on. Here's mu
which is 7.47 and we want to know if the new population parameter will be
significantly different. We decided significantly different if it falls in the
critical region. Remember that the z score here for an alpha level of .05 is
1.96. and negative 1.96. Where does the real population mean fall in the
distribution of sample means? Remember, that the standard deviation, of this
distribution, is the population standard deviation divided by the square root
of n. So the z-score of 7.8 is 7.8 minus 7.47. Divided by 2.41, divided by the
square root of 30. This is about 0.75. Since 0.75 is less than this z critical
value, but greater than this z critical value, the true population mean does
not fall within the critical region. But we don't know this, we base our
decision off of our sample. If we find the z score of our sample, We do the
same thing that we did here, but instead eight point three minus seven point
four seven divided by two point four one over root 30. And this is about one
point eight night. Therefore, our sample statistic also falls outside the
critical region Based on the results of this sample, we would fail to reject
the null, and in this case we made the right decision. Because this population
parameter also falls outside the critical region, close enough to the current
population mean. Since we retained the null when the null was true, then this
quadrant represents what happened.